[Musica]
qual è la relazione tra
bacchetta magica e telecomando
probabilmente nessuno in particolare per
tutti voi ma in realtà c'è una persona
che io conosco per cui questa relazione
importante ed è una persona che è nata
proprio in questa zona è nato a martano
a 94 anni ed è la nonna di mio marito
è quello che ci stupisce di lei quando
parla di questo telecomando e il fatto
che per lei è qualcosa di magico cioè
non riesce a spiegarsi come possa sto
facendo io in questo momento dare dei
comandi invisibili cioè sì probabilmente
viene lanciato un impulso questo impulso
arriva sul dispositivo cambia i canali
cambia da dei comandi però lei non lo
vede
ecco immaginate quante innovazioni ha
visto il 94 anni quanto ho visto il
mondo cambiare e quanto sia in grado di
meravigliarsi per questo è questa
meraviglia è qualcosa di magnifico ed è
qualcosa che spesso ci perdiamo cioè noi
non la viviamo questo tipo di meraviglia
e della meraviglia per rendersi conto
che c'è qualcosa che non si vede però
succede accade esiste ed è proprio la
magia perché la magia qualcosa che noi
non vediamo però sappiamo che esiste
ecco se c'è qualcosa che non vediamo ma
sappiamo che esiste ha un enorme impatto
sulla nostra vita e il digitale perché
il digitale quanto di più inconsistente
possa esserci e intangibile non
riusciamo neanche a capire come sia
fatto eppure influenza la nostra vita
diciamocelo influenza le nostre emozioni
i nostri vissuti le relazioni con le
persone di richiamo tantissimo tempo al
digitale e social network siti il nostro
lavoro di richiamo tantissimo tempo la
difficoltà però sta nel capire come è
fatto come e mappato e starai capire
come abitarlo perché possiamo scegliere
come abitare digitale c'è una scelta
possibile
il fatto è che appunto in questi anni ci
stiamo chiedendo come sia fatto come è
fatto questo digitale come lo stiamo
descrivendo lo stiamo disegnando
qualcuno dice che sia una sfera oppure
un piano oppure una somma di siti di
piattaforme una somma di cose di
contenuti che ci mettiamo dentro in
continuazione
il fatto è che ce li mettiamo dentro in
continuazione quindi fare una mappa una
cartografia e difficilissimo perché
cambia continuamente nel momento in cui
tu pensi di essere riuscito a mappare in
realtà non l'hai fatto e difficile anche
mappare un sito
noi cerchiamo di traslare quello che
facciamo a livello geografico su
internet ma non è veramente la stessa
cosa ecco questa è la grande difficoltà
per cui se vi chiedessi come voi ve lo
immaginate probabilmente mi dareste
risposte diverse ma sapreste che c'è
qualcosa che non riusciamo ancora a dire
ecco io credo che il digitale sia
innanzitutto uno spazio ed è uno spazio
vero e proprio non possiamo più
considerare il digitale come qualcosa
che non esiste perché effettivamente lo
abitiamo siamo abitanti del digitale il
fatto è che questo spazio è veramente
molto difficile da abitare ed è come se
fosse una gigantesca metropoli che è
fatta di bassifondi ma anche di piazze
di strade di attrazioni e che noi
attraversiamo e attraversiamo
velocissimamente a vista d'occhio ci
possiamo trovare da una parte dall'altra
possiamo connetterci con persone
lontanissime e la difficoltà sa proprio
nell'abitare questo tipo di realtà
perché servono strumenti tecnici
consapevolezza tecnica
educazione digitale ma anche degli
strumenti esistenziali perché non
sappiamo cosa ci troveremo è la ragione
per cui possiamo avere paura di far
usare ai bambini alle bambine ragazzi e
ragazze il digitale perché sappiamo che
ci sono delle cose pericolose
ecco
io parlo spesso di spazio pubblico
digitale e qui devo ammettere una cosa
cioè è è un po un gesto apotropaico io
parlo di spazio pubblico digitale perché
mi rendo conto che molto spesso questo
spazio non è pubblico non è uno spazio
che davvero condividiamo spesso siamo
separati nel digitale abbiamo idee
diverse
orari diversi valori diversi non ci
riusciamo a capire però mi sembra che
dirlo dire che possa esistere uno spazio
pubblico digitale sia importante perché
se non ci crediamo che possa esistere
allora di sicuro non ci sarà
e perché davvero c'è qualcosa che
funziona nello spazio digitale come
funziona nella realtà fisica
ecco vorrei leggere via proposito un
libro che io amo moltissimo che è
l'alleanza dei corpi di judith butler
lei una filosofa statunitense che ha
scritto questo libro alla luce di grandi
manifestazioni di piazza dimostrazioni
di piazza in cui gli spazi venivano resi
pubblici e quello che dice nell'alleanza
dei corpi e che i corpi si riuniscono si
muovono e parlano insieme rivendicano un
certo spazio in quanto pubblico sono le
stesse azioni collettive a creare lo
spazio a prendersi i marciapiedi e ad
animare organizzare le architetture i
corpi nella loro pluralità rivendicano
la sfera pubblica trovando e producendo
il pubblico attraverso l'occupazione e
la riconfigurazione
dell'ambiente materiale quindi siamo noi
a decidere quando uno spazio diventa
pubblico rai qualcosa di automatico
ci sono degli spazi sono pochissimi gli
spazi in cui c'è scritto questo era un
pazzo pubblico nella maggior parte dei
casi siamo noi come collettività che lo
decidiamo solo che dobbiamo percepirci
come collettività dobbiamo sentire che
si possa creare un'alleanza dobbiamo
sentire che sia acustico possibile
rendere pubblico uno spazio le fa
l'esempio per esempio dei dei carri
armati
immaginatevi sarà capitato di vedere
quelle foto in cui qualcuno sale su un
carro armato inizia a parlare alla folla
è un simbolo negativo diventa un simbolo
di coesione quello diventa uno spazio
pubblico perché non proviamo a pensare
che la stessa cosa possa accadere anche
negli spazi digitali è qualcosa che
effettivamente accade io l'ho vista
cadere moltissimo negli ultimi anni
quell'attivismo con la divulgazione ho
visto che c'erano delle persone che
hanno creduto che quella cosa fosse
possibile e l'hanno resa possibile e per
me è stato bellissimo vederlo perché ho
scoperto
tre storie delle esperienze delle
conoscenze che altrimenti non avrei
potuto scoprire non avrei potuto
conoscere ho scoperto che esistevano
altri mondi oltre al mio e che la mia
visione del mondo la mia descrizione del
mondo la piccola era chiusa e che invece
il mondo poteva essere molto più grande
di così solo che appunto bisogna
crederci
io immagino che voi stiate pensando è
però quando entri nello spazio digitale
è uno spazio così così strano da abitare
perché non è tangibile e allora le
intenzioni delle persone come fai a
capire quali possano essere c'è l'odio
in rete è molto difficile proteggersi da
quell odio ecco io queste dinamiche le
conosco molto bene perché sono stata
oggetto di odio in rete a tantissime
volte lo sono ancora oggi me ne sono
occupato molto anche con campagne di
sensibilizzazione ho cercato proprio di
capire come questo fenomeno globale si
potesse risolvere e ancora a distanza di
molti anni non riesco a capire perché
così tante persone possono pensare
scrivere dire delle cose così terribili
sugli altri esseri umani per fatto che
internet non rende le persone peggiori
le rivela
e questo è il fatto che nella realtà
fisica abbiamo convenzioni leggi abbiamo
una cultura che ci impedisce di dire
quello che pensiamo veramente che è
qualche modo pone un filtro tra le
persone su internet questo filtro non
c'è nel mondo digitale non ci sono i
filtri che ci sono nella realtà fisica
ma non è che diventiamo peggiori che
possiamo capire cosa veramente stiamo
pensando
e in effetti forse qualcuno di voi
potrebbero essere d'accordo con quello
che sto dicendo potrebbe giudicarlo
eccessivamente ottimista ma
probabilmente nessuno di voi si
alzerebbe qui in serie b a insultarmi e
forse invece chi vedesse questo video
girare su internet lo potrebbe fare
perché non considererebbe me come una
persona e quindi degna di rispetto e non
avrebbe gli stessi litri che invece voi
avete ecco questo esiste ma questo lo
facciamo noi
e vero che la maggior parte degli spazi
digitali sono spazi privati le
architetture sono immaginate da qualcun
altro però non è solo questo
siamo noi che disegniamo quegli spazi
c'è una grande responsabilità che è
nostra e allora cosa che dovremmo fare
secondo me ci sono due meraviglie che
dobbiamo riscoprire la prima è la
meraviglia dei dispositivi perché questi
strumenti di innovazione sono
potentissimi e davvero ci possono
permettere di fare delle cose
incredibili e dovremo scoprirli dovremo
cercare di essere curiosi e scoprire
come funzionano dovremmo domandarci ma
per me se io dovessi disegnare questo
spazi come sarebbe con sarebbe la realtà
digitale come vorrei abitarla dobbiamo
farcene queste domande perché uno spazio
condiviso lo spazio nostro la prima è
questa ma la seconda e la meraviglia
della relazione umana a che fare proprio
con
con il credere che quel telecomando sia
una bacchetta magica che la bacchetta
magica possa esistere tra esseri umani
una magia si possa creare tra esseri
umani c'è un'altra idea questo proposito
di judith butler che secondo me è
particolarmente importante che l'idea di
interdipendenza che non è un'idea
negativa non è una dipendenza dalle
altre persone
e un'inter dipendenza e la percezione
che da soli siamo molto meno di quello
che possiamo essere insieme che non
possiamo pensare da soli avrò bisogno
delle altre persone per pensare abbiamo
bisogno del dialogo abbiamo bisogno di
scoprire delle storie che non sono le
nostre abbiamo bisogno di sapere che
abbiamo il potere di rendere uno spazio
pubblico
abbiamo bisogno di crederci
quindi io vi dico che è vero che ci sono
che che che questi spazi spesso sono
privati è vero che spesso veniamo spinti
a comportarsi in un certo modo ma c'è
una grandissima responsabilità che è
nostra
e allora l'incontro tra gli esseri umani
non solo è possibile anche negli spazi
digitali ma è essenziale e lo dobbiamo
coltivare
e la ragione c'era dice ancora judith
butler se devo vivere una vita buona
sarà una vita vissuta insieme agli altri
una vita che non può essere chiamata
vita senza gli altri non perderò questo
io che io sono chiunque io sia verrò
trasformato dalle connessioni con gli
altri poiché la mia dipendenza dagli
altri e la mia dipende bilità sono
necessarie a vivere ea vivere bene una
vita buona non può essere una vita
solitaria ha bisogno del rischio
dell'incontro con gli altri esseri umani
il rischio del contatto fosse anche solo
anche solo per cominciare un contatto
digitale e allora questo rischio lo
creiamo noi questo incontro il rischio
di incontrare l'altra persona lo
dobbiamo creare ci dobbiamo credere
ecco in questo senso
tornando alla magia del telecomando si
tratta di coltivare questo tipo di
meraviglia di non dare per scontato che
se le cose sono così oggi saranno così
anche domani di non dare per scontato
che tutte le persone abbiano voglia solo
di lanciarsi strali sul web perché in
realtà ci sono tantissime persone che
hanno voglia invece di incontrarsi di
condividere ricchezza e allora pensare
che tanto è impossibile è facile e
comodo perché una petizione di principio
cioè un ragionamento che si auto
conferma sono abbiamo una visione del
mondo cinica il mondo ci sarà ci darà
tantissime occasioni per confermarla è
facilissimo ma se invece pensiamo che
sia possibile fare qualcosa di diverso
allora sequel è più faticoso ma è molto
più interessante e molto più avventuroso
pensare che sia possibile
non significa credere di vivere nel
migliore dei mondi possibili
ma significa credere che un mondo
migliore sia possibile da creare e
dipende veramente moltissimo da noi
ecco
spesso rischiamo quando diventiamo
adulti di credere che le cose stiano
così e non possono cambiare non si
possano trasformare che le altre persone
siano solo dei nemici e non degli
incontri possibili che ci possano allora
ripensando a alla nonna di 94 anni che
ancora si stupisce per delle cose per
cui noi spesso non ci stupiamo io vi
dico pensiamo che certe cose siano
possibili e pensiamo lo nell'ordine del
possibile pensiamo le come
irrealizzabili come fattibili e questo
non solo per le altre persone per essere
buoni ma per avere una vita buona
ecco io credo che sia questa la magia
sia questo è credere che questa
consistenza dell'invisibile sia qualcosa
che ci possa arricchire quindi crediamo
in questo contatto con gli altri esseri
umani che forse la magia più importante
che possiamo avere
crediamo che le altre persone ci possano
dare in tutti gli spazi di incontro
possibile in tutti gli spazi di
dibattito anche quelli sgangherati e
semplificanti come quelli digitali che
ci possano dare qualcosa che da soli non
potremo avere uno sguardo diverso
rispetto al nostro
non è forse questa è la magia grazie
[Applauso]